time to draft the quarterback movement
we'd like to see this offseason peter
and we've got a trivia question this is
going to be a joint project because i
don't expect you to get all five we're
going to work on this together i'm going
to give you the first pick anyway but
here's the question i'm fascinated by
this
five american colleges have had both a
u.s president and a super bowl winning
quarterback as alumni
name the five schools i can think at two
i'm i'm beyond that i'm just throwing
darts
uh michigan is one
with gerald ford and tom brady
what do you got
i got delaware joe biden and joe flacco
all right
after that
how about stanford stanford
yeah there we go
um
and three uh
texas there's a small college right
small college in a flyover state says
matt casey
somewhere somewhere in ohio
what would it be in ohio
i'm an idiot tell us let's give me let's
go let's see what they are i don't know
i don't
oh ben ben roethlisberger the miami
redhawks
roger staubach navy oh navy okay so
who's the president from miami of ohio
[Music]
benjamin harrison of course
how could you not know that come on
yeah
i i will hang my head in shame
all right uh you get the first pick
quarterback movement we'd like to see
deshaun watson to the jets hate to be a
cliche
but i want to see deshaun watson in that
sort of shanahan
uh you know mike lafleur
uh class of coach where
you really take a lot of pressure off
the quarterback
and you give him solutions every time he
drops back to pass plus
i think joe douglas
is a really good personnel guy he's
going to find players and robert sala is
going to know how to coach them i like
the jets and i'm and plus deshawn watson
wants to go there it's a good trade
partner for houston you trade them sam
darnold the number two pick in the draft
and next year's won
and
hope that that gets the job done
and remember watson wanted the texans to
interview salah the texans the only team
of seven with vacancies this year that
did not interview robert sala i want to
see matthew stafford go to the
indianapolis colts i think it makes too
much sense to not happen
dome
stadium
for stafford in detroit dome in
indianapolis they need that quarterback
who can be plug and play probably better
option than philip rivers at this point
in their respective careers still fairly
young still can get it done and needs to
have good leadership and good coaching
around him he i don't think he's ever
had consistent
good coaching and i don't think he's
ever had true leaders in the locker room
and it's something that i feel like he
doesn't want to do so i think
indianapolis would make a lot of sense
and they would be a factor again in the
afc if they haven't peter
i'd like to see jared goff go to the new
england patriots um i'd like to see goff
in maybe a less frenetic kind of offense
and i'd like to see him coached by josh
mcdaniels and i'd like to see the
patriots go out and draft
sign and free agency some skilled
players to give goff a chance
well unless they're going to build a
dome in new england i don't see jared
goff playing for the patriots because he
doesn't like to play in the cold if you
haven't noticed but uh maybe he would
get used to it after some practices out
there in the northeast next one for me i
want to see kirk cousins go to the 49ers
for a couple of reasons i want the
vikings to move on from kirk cousins i'm
sorry i just do i just do he loves him
he loves him he loves him not i think
it's time for a change in minnesota in a
lot of ways frankly but uh
kyle shanahan one of the reasons he
didn't go after patrick mahomes or
deshaun watson in the 2017 draft is he
had his sights set on getting kirk
cousins as a free agent a year later and
the jimmy garoppolo trade happened in
between but i feel like it's it's
destined for those two to get together
and i know 49ers fans freak out when i
try to make that argument i was on radio
in san francisco a week or two ago but
cousins at least is going to be
available to play he's not going to be
hurt 75 percent of the time cousins
never miss his time so put him in that
offense and
let him develop consistency and you pair
him up with that defense i think it
could be a good pairing i don't know
what the vikings would do for
quarterback but i got some ideas maybe
later in the draft
well if you had just said that before
my last pick i would have then given
garoppolo to the patriots because i'd
love to see that happen
but i just think at the end of the day i
think the 49ers are going to sniff
around the edges of all these derbies
uh and for some reason i think they're
going to be back with garoppolo not that
they not that that's a unanimous slam
dunk but that's kind of what i think
i'll give you one
that i think pro football focus had it
had it right on the nose jameis winston
to the carolina panthers
you know they got a c year out of teddy
bridgewater
not really what they were hoping for and
i think joe brady the offensive
coordinator at carolina wants a
quarterback who can throw the ball
downfield to his speed receivers
and keep in mind mike
deepest uh
deepest average target in the nfl over
the last five years jameis winston now
he's throwing a lot of picks don't we
all know that but
i think they want to have a daryl
lamonica
deep strike offense in carolina i'd love
to see jameis winston do that
and this is a follow to that and a
companion to my prior pick i want to see
teddy bridgewater go back to minnesota i
don't know why the panthers are so down
on him all of a sudden you get this vibe
that they're looking and they're looking
and they're looking and bridgewater's
not good enough why'd you give him a
three-year 66 million dollar contract if
you think he's not good enough i think
bridgewater has shown incredible growth
he's come so far from that torn acl that
supposedly was going to end his career
it would just be one hell of a story i
always root for a great story and it
would be one hell of a story to see
bridgewater back in minnesota and
finally fulfill that potential that he
was on the brink of realizing before
that horrible knee injury we got one
more round or that's it
we got one more round if you want one
okay if we're gonna do one more round
i'm gonna do a preposterous one okay i
want aaron rodgers to go to the patriots
he's the second quarterback i'm giving
to the patriots and and he's not going
there you know it's like mark murphy
says we're not idiots we're not trading
aaron rodgers and they shouldn't trade
aaron rodgers i would just love to see
i'd love to see bill belichick coach
aaron rodgers i'd love to see josh
mcdaniels coach aaron rodgers and i
think aaron rodgers would love to go
somewhere that has suddenly become a
little bit of an underdog
you know because the patriots now nobody
expects them to do anything if aaron
rodgers could take that team
you know and play like a championship
game
in kansas city against patrick mahomes
at some point in the next two three
years now that would be like the cap on
bill belichick's coaching career
all right i'll see your preposterous and
i'll go slightly more preposterous i
want to see derek carr just because i
love chaos and when chaos arrives i want
to maximize it i want derek carr to the
houston texans following in his
brother's footsteps almost 20 years
later they didn't draft him because it
didn't go well with derek carr but you
know what the hell it's all turned
upside down in houston they may need a
quarterback and maybe if john gruden can
get himself a matthew stafford or a cam
newton or someone else he'd move on from
derek carr so that was
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports